Michael's in Fort Worth Texas hey
Michael welcome to Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave can I speak with you today you too
sir how can I help
well we want to put in a pool and a
swimming pool and I'm having these huge
swings we guess let's do it
no put it on the house dummy and I'm not
sure if it's God talking to me and I'd
like your opinion
not just from a real estate standpoint
but what would David Sharon do hmm what
will the pool cost fifty thousand okay
and what's your home worth home is worth
375 okay how many pools are in your
neighborhood I think there's one other
one okay so they're not normal in your
neighborhood yep and how many homes in
your neighborhood sell for over 400,000
or most of them under 4 over 4 right at
about 4 ok so you're going to be top of
the neighborhood if you took 375 and put
50 on top of it that before and a
quarter right yes sir so the translation
is you're not going to get your money
out of this pool you're going to have to
swim some of it I agree
okay so you might increase the value
half of the cost of the pool it sounds
like but it's not gonna it's there's not
a lot of pools in your area so they're
not normative so they're not it's not
going to add a ton of value it's not
holding you back but my guess is and you
can have a real estate agent come out
and actually tell you and say if I put a
pool on this how much will increase the
value and they'll tell you and they can
look at it and I'll give you a guess
about half it sounds like to me okay I
don't think that the I think you reach a
point of diminishing returns in your
neighborhood when you get to 400 grand
you see what I'm saying yeah so what you
say your household income is about 120
okay so you're paying cash for the pool
well we have 14,000 in the pool fund
right now but another year of saving and
we'll have 50 okay if you pay cash for
it and you understand we just spent
$25,000 on a
we and and we're gonna have to play with
that toy a lot because it's worth zero
the other 25000 will probably get back
out when we sell the house and as long
as you have that understanding of it
emotionally I don't think what you're
doing stupid you paying cash for it
would we do that well we might we might
we have a pool at our house it was we
put it on we built it we don't use it a
lot but kind of those infinity-edge
things we're up on a mountain but you
know I've you know that's what you'd
want and it doesn't sound like it's
ridiculous in your situation but that's
how I would do the analysis the way I
described it to you the critical
thinking on it this is the Dave Ramsey
show